it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week if you thought
there was still a video game drought you
obviously haven't heard of a badass
elephant named Timbo as the national
army struggles to contain the
devastating forces of phantom on their
poor shale city they call upon a hero
who's worth his weight in weapons aided
by his faithful bandanna wielding flying
friend piccolo Tembo but stomps his way
through hordes of enemies in a 2d
side-scrolling adventure with 17 comic
books styled levels start working for
peanuts on the 21st
basement fans of binding of issac will
be happy to know rebirth is coming to
Xbox one new 3ds and WiiU this week
which is quite interesting considering
Nintendo weren't big fans of the games
religious themes and content but simply
by putting a leaf over Isaacs doodle and
replacing God with dog the game somehow
skirted Nintendo's offensive meter and
is now allowed for purchasing fans will
be happy to know that other than those
minor edits all the content is still in
its true form so you'll get the full
creepy weird experience that you wanted
take down your mama on the 23rd the
sleeper hit Talos principle which was
critically acclaimed in its initial
release in 2014
gets a highly sought after DLC this week
titled road to Gehenna you're taking on
the role of Uriel with a four episode
expansion with a whole new set of
puzzles that'll have you scratching your
gold-plated head nothing has been said
about the story so far but it's got the
same writers so you can expect nothing
but the best set your expectations to
unmatchable the DLC drops on PC July
23rd America you waited patiently and
you're gonna be rewarded for it f1 is
officially out in the States on console
it's been out since July ninth most
everywhere else and you can currently
grab it on PC but it's not recommended
as it crashes more than Andrei adichie
Zuri's so I would steer clear of that
one until a patch comes in America gets
f1 on the 21st finally one of the most
tremendous games I've ever had the
pleasure of playing coming out on ps4
this week giving us all a reason to
enjoy it again
run around on smooth golden sand dunes
with mysterious blanketed partners in a
game that proves stranger is just a
friend you haven't met did I mention the
music was grammy-nominated everything
about this game is amazing at one
GameSpot's game of the year so if you
haven't played it play it and if you
have played it play it again
it's that good for further details visit
GameSpot calm release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week